good morning believe nation today's
message is just do it over to you Jack
Dorsey just do it a lot of time is spent
thinking about something oh yeah I'm
talking about it you know but when you
actually get something down either on
paper or in code or you know in front of
someone that's when things start
happening and you're going to make a lot
of mistakes the important thing is that
you make decisions and you keep moving
forward but you have to get it out there
yeah you have to start and you have to
be brave enough to to take the criticism
may I always go back to the punk
movement of the 70s mm-hmm people would
get out there be on the street cuz you
were a teenager back then yeah and they
say there would be a there would be
learning in front of people like they
get out on the street and it's the first
time with a guitar yeah and you know
they're learning how to play and they're
getting better and better and better
yeah um and I think that's really
important to just get it down do it just
do it it edit it so what do you think
the absolute first thing that comes to
mind is that that's the Nike slogan and
that's awesome but you know just do it I
think everything that we want in our
life whether it's business success
whether it's you know we want to achieve
you know our passion projects it's the
relationships that we want to have
whatever it is that we want to have in
our lives really comes down to us taking
massive action to getting there and I
think a lot of people get stuck in the
planning phase in the I have an idea
phase but what if this happens phase all
right plan they don't get acting they
don't jump in and actually start doing
things to start you know getting things
in motion right law of inertia right
things that are in motion
in motion right and I also think that
when you start doing things you're not
asked you're asking better questions and
what I mean by this is that in the
beginning when you're not doing anything
you're asking questions like well what
if everyone that I love rejects me what
if everyone around me makes fun of me
what if I sound stupid what if no one
watches alright you're asking all these
questions that are coming from a place
of lack so instead of coming from a
place of lack you have to ask better
questions and when you start doing
things now it's a questions of
refinement how can I get more viewers
how can I make my content more
compelling how can I story tell better
how can I do X Y Z so the frame of it is
you're not looking you're not it's not
coming from a place of am i enough right
it's coming from I'm already doing it
right now how do I get this to be better
and I think that's really moving the
chains right it's really actually
getting you to the place that you want
to be in I'm gonna change there as
football yeah moving the chains there
you go like yeah I think so many people
are so afraid to fail that they don't
even try if you guys want to start a
YouTube channel right a lot of you have
me have a goal I want to be a youtuber
great and so I'm not going to start
though until I get the camera on the
tripod and the lights and I got a
research and I got to watch all these
videos about how to be a youtuber and
you know get by the e-book and listen to
the podcast and all this stuff about how
to be a youtuber before I start this has
to be perfect first step and if it's not
perfect then I'm not going to do it and
you never actually get in front of a
camera and make a video right and you're
the world's expert on lights now and
cameras in here and all this stuff and
you've never even made a single video
right people plan and prepare and so
worried of making that first step there
is no perfect first step the perfect
first step is to do something and the
stop just thinking about and stop just
planning it actually takes some action
there are some people who just do and go
crazy and they do too much it I don't
plan enough but most people playing way
too much and they don't ever take any
action because they're too afraid
because they're afraid they go back to
what is safe and comfortable which is
more planning more planning until I
figure out all the answers and you won't
freak out the answers until you actually
go out and start taking some action so
whatever it is that thing that you've
been putting off for that big scary
project
like one day I'm gonna do this just
break it down do one small tiny thing
towards making it happen that's a big
step don't go sell your house you know
don't go take out a big mortgage don't
do something crazy one small simple step
and the tomorrow another step it's for
another step and people I think are too
focused on taking giant leaps or if you
look at the people who've taken the
giant leaps it's just an accumulation of
little steps that they've taken
consistently just do it yeah I think
it's everyday showing up right it's
being consistent every day doing
something creating something right it
doesn't mean you have to create let's
take your example of someone starting a
YouTube channel it doesn't mean to have
to now do seven videos a week and you
know there's their mate and you know
amazingly overwhelmed it's about
creating one video a week and then just
getting in that practice of thinking
about creating and you know having
building that creating muscle right and
in that in that example I think that's
helping people to just go out there and
actually do it so the question of the
day today is what is one moment in your
life where you saw someone or you did
just do it
mentality and it worked out or it didn't
work out share your experiences leave it
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot up and press Oh